ça c'est le meilleur ami de mes
intestins et de mon anus bah quoi tu as
pas un petit tabouret pour mettre tes
pieds dessus quand tu crottes toi bah tu
devrais c'est pas pour faire joli c'est
anatomique regarde cette espèce de
sangle là c'est le muscle puborectal
d'un côté il est accroché au pubis et de
l'autre il entoure le rectum c'est la
toute dernière partie de l'intestin
juste avant le grand plongeon quand on
est debout ou assis le muscle il est
tendu donc il tire sur le rectum il le
coude et le caca passe pas bien alors
que quand tes genoux sont au-dessus de
tes hanches il est relâché donc le
rectum est tout droit bien dans l'axe de
la sortie du toboggan là et plouf des
tabourets tu peux en trouver des tout
faits ou customiser le tien comme moi
franchement c'est pas cher ça prend pas
de place et ton anus te dira merci merci